we are now 20 days into the war in
ukraine newly released drone video shows
fire damage to the apartment buildings
in the southern city of mariupol you can
see black smoke there billowing into the
sky ukrainian officials say more than
two and a half thousand civilians have
been killed there so far russia has
failed to take the city on the country's
southern coast russian forces have also
been advancing on the capital kiev this
video that's new today shows the
aftermath of another strike on a
residential building we have extensive
coverage for you of the war in ukraine
including from nora o'donnell on the
ukraine border but we're going to begin
in keep with charlie dagetta and the
latest on the fighting mayor charlie
good morning to you
good morning at around five o'clock this
morning a number of explosions rang out
across the city in one of the heaviest
bombardments since the invasion began in
a worrying sign the mayor has just
announced a new curfew from tonight
through thursday morning
overnight the russian military machine
turned its guns on the capitol itself
raining down on residential
neighborhoods igniting an apartment
block into an inferno
the mayor estimates more than half of
kyiv's population of around 3.1 million
has already fled to safer regions or
left the country altogether while some
have taken up semi-permanent residents
deep inside the city's subway system
even sleeping out in trains
in the wooded outskirts of the city
ukrainian soldiers have dug in letting
fellow ukrainians and russian forces for
that matter know about it but we see for
ourselves this is no show
every single road is barricaded and
manned by troops reservists or
volunteers
like 32 year old vladimir an economist
who lived and worked in dc a few years
back it may be that you will have to
fight yeah we have we already fight we
were ready for them
they were
you know in ukraine they told who comes
to us will die here at a local auto
repair shop macgyver meets mad max
they've ripped the weapons off ruined
russian military vehicles and oleg
modifies them for use by ukrainian
fighters
you must smile every time you see a new
one come in
because it's one less gun shooting this
way and one more gun shooting that way
in an overnight address president
vladimir zelinski made an appeal
directly to russian soldiers
on behalf of the ukrainian people i give
you a chance a chance to survive he said
if you surrender to our forces we will
treat you the way people are supposed to
be treated as people decently
despite days of flattening suburbs like
urpan and bucha including renewed
shelling overnight ground troops have
yet to advance to the capital
but many here fear keeve awaits the same
fate as places like the port city of
mariopo which has suffered from the full
fury of russian firepower for days
parkeev where russian forces unleashed
new artillery strikes in an effort to
capture ukraine's second largest city
across the country ukraine's tenacious
forces refuse to give up ground but
cities under siege and civilians are
paying a heavy price